all right everyone
chill
in a world oversaturated with superhero
movies it goes without saying that not
all of them are super but what makes the
good ones great gloriously epic team ups
tragic deaths of previously invincible
badasses keep watching to see what we
think are the 55 greatest superhero
movies ever made
short order cook frank darbo has lived a
lackluster life until he becomes a
crimson bolt after hearing the word of
god or at least what he thinks is the
word of god with the help of his
sidekick bolty he sets out to rescue his
estranged wife from a brutal man by any
means necessary the heroes in super wear
and practically bright costumes that
look straight out of the most
kid-friendly comics ever created but
their crime-fighting techniques look
more like the unsettling violence of the
sopranos james gunn's first
feature-length foray into the land of
capes and masks unfolds as a commentary
on the superhero genre's contradictions
and serves as a trial for concepts he'd
revisit in hbo's peacemaker
the sequel to deadpool cranks up the
gleefully r-rated gore general zaniness
and earnest heart that lots of folks
connected with the first time around
running time traveler cable zaps into
wade wilson's reality to slaughter a
future tyrant however the alleged baddie
is a troubled kid wade can't help but
protect prison breaks mutant team-ups
and ludicrous violence ensue deadpool 2
successfully introduces time travel to
deadpool's proverbial toolbox of story
devices sassy beats effortlessly prompts
discussions about whether a domino solo
movie could work with her winning
performance and opening theme ashes
marks celine dion's finest film
soundtrack effort since titanic
a devout mormon becomes an adult film
star who never actually does the deed on
camera however he does fight crime with
his unmatched martial arts expertise and
the orgasm raider raygun the effects of
which will leave up to your imagination
the 90s produced as many superhero
spoofs as earnest entries into the genre
but orgasmo is not interested in making
fun of superheroes exclusively an early
feature by south park creators matt
stone and trey parker orgasmo also
skewers both organized religion and the
adult film industry did we mention this
movie is nc-17 because it's nc-17
captain america civil war sees captain
america and iron man driven apart by the
sokovia accords a proposed set of
regulations for the avengers and their
extra human ilk it's also the marvel
movie where spider-man and black panther
show up the russo brothers focus on
spectacular action set pieces and
expanding the mcu without dwelling
excessively on the politics of the
matter watching spider-man team up with
iron man is worth the price of admission
alone but contemplation on the avengers
legality makes the whole affair uniquely
intriguing
a quintessential childhood film for
anyone born in the 1980s the first
cinematic journey of the teenage mutant
ninja turtles draws heavily from the
original comics by kevin eastman and
peter laird a mysterious crime wave is
engulfing new york city and only the
turtles can stop it but when their wise
rap mentor master splinter is captured
what are they supposed to do team up
with new allies like news reporter april
o'neil of course considering its
technical innovations and kid-friendly
metaphors for grown-up subject matter
this movie can hold its own alongside
any classic fantasy film of the 80s
baymax is a helpful robot made of
balloons his creator's little brother
irreverent teenager hero builds him a
flying mech suit and the pair go on
adventures with a social circle of
similarly brilliant teenagers but a
microbot wielding villain is menacing
the city and hiro is after all just a
kid can he possibly stop this masked
menace with baymax's help it just might
be possible what you might not realize
is that big hero 6 is based on a marvel
comic from the 90s so its comic book
pedigree is real making it a movie not
to be missed
while the 1960s batman series doesn't
take itself seriously the most swinging
version of the dynamic duo aren't
messing around and their quest to make
gotham a safe and prosperous city you
might even say this batman and robin are
serious men in an unserious world in
this movie which spins out from the tv
program the not so dark night's most
devious foes form an organization known
as the united underworld whose plot
involves turning diplomats into powder
with a dehydration gun on a separate
occasion their plot involves an
exploding shark yes it's goofy and fun
as heck
while king phoenix's oscar-winning
performance as the clown prince of crime
runs the gamut from tragic to
blisteringly psychotic and joker a
unique supervillain and name only film
arthur fleck lives a disappointing life
in a disappointing world as his stand-up
career flatlines he becomes enmeshed in
the violence that defines gotham city
and nothing is ever the same again a
nihilistic exploration of a character
moviegoers never seem to tire of joker
is a memorable vision of misery and
madness
immortal frenemies charles xavier and
magneto ally and x-men first class a
movie that explores the x-men's early
60s origins brought together by ideals
and experience the two men head up what
will become marvel's most famous band of
mutants but as the world changes so do
they which future should mutants pursue
xavier's vision of coexistence or
magneto's dream of mutant supremacy the
fact that this film is still
entertaining despite having barely any
wolverine in it is a testimony to its
originality
colloquially referred to as the snyder
cut zack snyder's justice league is a
maximalist take on the dc universe and a
totally unprecedented do-over of a major
studio blockbuster in the movie batman
and wonder woman must rally earth's
to fend off an invasion from the planet
apocalypse it's a noble effort but what
hope does the fledgling justice league
have against darkseid when earth's
greatest champion the man of steel is
dead
aquaman cyborg and the flash rally
regardless but they might not be
prepared for what's facing them
a reverent depiction of one of the most
enduring origin stories in comics wonder
woman stands apart from the pack after
pilot steve trevor crash lands on the
island of the amazons princess diana
must join the fight ravaging the planet
but aries immortal enemy of peace is
ready for her and her god-killing sword
a sweeping story packed with engaging
performances wonder woman does right by
a comic book icon as a world war one
period piece with leads who have vivid
romantic chemistry
marvel studios and sony finally put
their differences aside allowing
spider-man to take his rightful place at
the heart of the mcu and homecoming in
his first headlining gig in the red and
blue spandex tom holland's peter parker
squares off against the sinister vulture
but the brand new spidey is also just a
kid who wants to enjoy high school go to
parties and maybe romance's crush what's
a super-powered teen to do trying to
balance it all of course this take on
the classic hero is particularly
enlivened by peter's friends ned and mj
played winningly by jacob babylon and
zendaya
batman headlines a lot of terrific
movies but this is the only one that
ends with everyone in gotham city
dancing and singing along to a song
about friendship this refreshingly
offbeat spin on the dark knight pits him
against the joker but also himself
people especially the eager young robin
want to be a part of his life but he
insists on solitude can batman learn the
value of friendship before it's too late
the lego batman movie is a celebration
of comic book tropes found families and
of course little plastic building blocks
a wildly underrated addition to the
ninja turtles franchise 2007's tmnt
brings the brothers back together after
an extended sabbatical from anti-evil
activity there's an immortal warlord on
the loose but can they reunite in time
to stop him well some adaptations barely
differentiate the turtles from each
other in this movie leo raph mikey and
don all come across as distinct
individuals bonded by a shared history
rather than just a mutual appreciation
of pizzas and catchphrases that's not to
say the turtles don't like pizza or
catchphrases in this movie though they
absolutely do
margot robbie's harley quinn breaks up
with the joker after suicide squad and
embarks upon a crime spree of her own in
birds of prey members of gotham's
supporting cast previously on scene in
the dc extended universe huntress renee
montoya cassandra kane and black canary
make their first appearances here as
harley's unlikely band of butt kickers
they're out to take down underworld boss
roman tsionis but can they truly tackle
his empire of cruelty the energy of this
movie is deadpool meets heathers on
literal roller skates
while wearing a stolen rocket pack
invented by eccentric businessman howard
hughes protagonist cliff sucker can fly
a tremendous speed and by doing so earn
some unwanted attention meanwhile 1930s
america is lousy with secret nazi agents
whose faces are all in need of punching
when the two combine you get an exciting
and interesting film based on dave
stevens's rocketeer comics that still
stands up today
ryan reynolds spun a career defining
triumph out of total humiliation with
deadpool while he technically plays wade
wilson in 2009's x-men origins wolverine
that movie's version of deadpool has
functionally nothing in common with
marvel's beloved absurdist anti-hero
reynolds and director tim miller made
darn sure to get wade right on the
second try after he's left permanently
disfigured but also unkillable by brutal
experimentation wade wilson becomes
deadpool a fourth wall breaking maniac
out for revenge i got places to be a
face to fix and oh
bad guys to kill
what results is loaded with stunningly
gratuitous violence gut-busting hilarity
and one of the greatest x-men team-ups
ever
black widow is an explosive espionage
endeavor which provides an effective
bridge between disparate parts of the
mcu natasha romanov is eager to leave
her past behind but the other black
widows created in the fearsome red room
need her help so does elena the woman
who once posed as her little sister
florence pugh's inaugural turn as elena
is so excellent it immediately caused
fans to wonder when she'd be getting her
own trilogy
loosely inspired by a 1982 miniseries by
chris claremont and frank miller the
wolverine sends hugh jackman's logan on
a self-contained adventure in japan far
away from any reminder of the other
x-men there he's stripped of his healing
ability confronted with the ghosts of
his past and forced to battle high-tech
samurai the wolverine feels like the
first cinematic x-men tale in which
logan's virtual immortality meaningfully
informs the story which proves to be a
memorable hook
the final entry in christopher nolan's
dark knight trilogy offers a colossal
chaotic and ultimately fitting close to
christian bale's tenure under the cowl
bane a masked revolutionary is out to
reduce gotham city to rubble part of
this plan sees him destroy bruce wayne's
life in every possible way
batman will need all of his cleverness
strength and resolve to emerge from the
pit bane consigns him to but even that
might not be enough
while the inaugural pair of dc eu movies
man of steel and batman vs superman are
known for their polarizing grimness
shazam offers a much brighter take on
its source material that still manages
to keep its feet on the ground during an
otherwise normal subway ride young billy
batson comes in contact with an ancient
wizard who names billy his champion
empowered to become the grown-up
superhero shazam whenever he speaks that
magical name aloud billy gains new
abilities that help him fight dr
savannah but more importantly they allow
him to bond with his foster family
eventual prestige filmmaker guillermo
del toro guides what could have been a
rote supernatural martial arts keeper
into an achievement of campy b-movie
blood and guts in this killer film evil
vampires recruit human vampire hybrid
blade to help them fight even eviler
vampires can this unlikely team up
prevail before the planet is scoured of
all life blade 2 is exciting bizarre and
entertaining as heck
it's only flaw it might also leave you
with an inflated notion of techno
music's popularity during the early odds
not long after the first hellboy came
out guillermo del toro went from being a
highly respected mid-level horror
fantasy director to the brains behind an
oscar-nominated dark fairy tale
his enhanced reputation is reflected in
the scope and aesthetic sensibilities of
the sequel the titular demonic hero
takes on a tremendously powerful
mechanical army in this one as well as
the uncaring world what's a big red
member of hell's royal family to do
describing it as blade 2 going
one-on-one with pan's labyrinth then a
demolition derby feels like an
oversimplification but it's also the
most accurate way to describe the golden
army
tom holland's second solo spider-man
sojourn sends a gang from the midtown
school of science and technology on a
european field trip peter hopes to take
a break from doing spider-man stuff and
spend some time with mj you should pack
your suit just in case i have a tingle
about it
please stop saying tingle may
of course inexplicable attacks from
building sized elemental monsters screw
that plan up entirely good thing the
evidently benign quentin beck is here to
help right all the while peter in the
world grief tony stark who seems to have
left an unfillable chasm at the heart of
the super heroic world
kneel
a source of that iconic line superman 2
cranks up the volume on the wide-eyed
golden age of comic-style kookiness of
the first superman kryptonian conquerors
have arrived on earth and decide to take
it for their own superman must stop them
while also nurturing his burgeoning
romance with lois lane in 1980 it had
barely occurred to anyone that
superheroes could be ridden with angst
superman 2 is gritty and raw by the
standards of its day which means it's a
refreshingly balanced production to
modern eyes
the launch of a whole new batman begins
as an obsessive grim iteration of bruce
wayne prowls a particularly dark gotham
city the batman places extra emphasis on
the caped crusader's reputation as a
detective as he hunts a flamboyant
serial killer version of the riddler and
unravels a criminal conspiracy that ties
together many of gotham's business and
political elites to his shock this
includes thomas wayne
a retelling of one of history's earliest
superhero stories and the definitive
modern zorro movie the mask of zorro
vibrates on both old and current
frequencies here an epic team up between
the original zorro fresh from prison and
the new zorro takes place they're both
aiming to take down a corrupt governor
and his bill in his henchmen but
bringing him to his knees won't be easy
adventure romance and glamour are all on
offer here set off by no small amount of
flair
no bad
no but at all
the third spider-man movie starring tom
holland is a culmination of almost two
decades worth of storytelling across two
major film studios and three fictional
universes it's hard to even imagine such
a scenario ever coming to pass just as
it's hard to imagine a more heartfelt
celebration of the wall crawler's legacy
in movies peter parker has accidentally
ripped open the multiverse which draws
enemies from the spidey versus headed up
by toby maguire and andrew garfield add
in some devastating losses and an
unforgettable choice that will change
peter's life forever you have a truly
great modern superhero movie
before he can be unthawed in modern
times and introduced to the rest of
earth's mightiest heroes young steve
rogers must become a science experiment
gone haywire a mascot for the american
military and finally the allies premiere
one-man nazi killing machine can one
juiced up kid from brooklyn truly make a
difference on the battlefields of world
war ii that's exactly what we're gonna
do
but not without help haley atwell is a
particularly strong ally she generates
an onslaught of charisma solidifying
agent peggy carter's mcu presence into
the indefinite future
literally 20 years ahead of its time
mystery men clearly would have been a
gargantuan hit in 2019 his sensibilities
run alongside superhero satires like the
boys and deadpool mr furious's power is
that he gets really really angry the
shoveler shovels exceptionally well
carol carries a bowling ball that's
haunted by the poltergeist of her
overbearing father captain amazing is a
big name crime fighter far more obsessed
with his image than saving the world
together they're out to save champion
city while we didn't appreciate it
during its debut we can at least
celebrate mystery men today as one of
the first truly offbeat cape flicks
the suicide squad towers over its
similarly named 2016 predecessor this
time around amanda waller deploys a
squadron of villains and misfits to
quarter maltese aiming to neutralize the
murky project starfish as is usually the
case with amanda waller not all is as it
seems voicing king shark sylvester
stallone is essentially the
cannibalistic root of this movie that
alone is worth checking out but it helps
that this archaic joyride also features
margot robbie's irresistible harley
quinn and john cena's hilarious debut as
peacemaker
whether scott pilgrim himself deserves
superhero status is clearly a debatable
matter however scott pilgrim vs the
world is definitely a comic book movie
with superheroes in it this is michael
sarah being as michael sarah as ever in
the lead role who must fight the seven
evil exes of mysterious ramona flowers
if he wants to date her prepare to feel
the wrath of the league of evil axes
league of eagle axes
you really don't know about the league
infused with video game and indie rock
references scott pilgrim is a self-aware
action-packed rob that's a joy to watch
from beginning to end chris evans
brandon routh and bree larson all throw
down in the supporting cast
after 2000's x-men demonstrated that
superhero movies could be financially
viable again sam raimi stepped up to the
plates with his take on the iconic wall
crawler spider-man is a comic book movie
that unapologetically behaves like a
comic book movie peter parker's journey
from hapless nerd to diligent superhero
is completely and thrillingly classic in
battling the green goblin he must decide
what sacrifices he's truly willing to
make this dynamite movie reminds us once
again that great power and great
responsibility are like cream cheese and
bagels the first is no good without the
second tim burton's batman established
the template for modern batflakes where
adam west's bruce of the 60s tells us to
fast on our seat belts and look both
ways before crossing the street michael
keaton's bruce wayne will get nuts if
circumstances demand that he do so now
you want to get nuts come on let's get
nuts
or you ever dance with the devil in the
pale moonlight
and boy do they demand it he must face
off against jack nicholson's joker in
this flick who so ably performs the role
that it took heath ledger's career
defining take on the joker to eclipse
him this gotham city is weird mean
glamorous and still one of a kind
in this rollicking flick star-lord aka
peter quill assembles his ragtag crew of
outcasts to keep an infinity stone out
of the hands of intergalactic warlord
ronin the accuser if you're watching the
mcu through for the first time keep an
eye on those infinity stones they turn
out to be pretty important james gunn
somehow lulls us into suspending
disbelief for the sake of implausible
characters like rocket raccoon and groot
a tree who can only say i'm groot
what results is electric bizarre and
immensely fun
you can't have a real conversation about
superhero movies without a lot of focus
on batman and you can't have a real
conversation about batman and media
without discussing batman the animated
series the theatrically released batman
mask of the phantasm is basically a
feature-length episode of the series
it's also one of the most effective deep
dives into the dark knight's inner
motivations and conflicts ever committed
to celluloid here the caped crusader
must confront his past when a masked
killer cuts a wide swath through gotham
city's underground but the truth is even
more intense than he could ever have
imagined
tony stark is a spoiled brilliant war
profiteer shocked into humility by a
brutal kidnapping upon escape he decides
to change the trajectory of his life and
put the superpowered armor he's built to
good use unfortunately not all of his
business partners are crazy about this
idea iron man could stand on its own as
an entirely solid techno action endeavor
but it becomes something truly special
in its historically crucial post-credit
scene believe it or not back in 2008
folks didn't understand they had to sit
through the credits of marvel movies
this flick changed that forever
while its legacy is dominated by the
onset death of 28 year old star brandon
lee the crow successfully channeled the
grim urban warfare and mortal ambiguity
of 80s comics years before the dceu did
when musician eric draven rises from the
dead he discovers he has fantastic
abilities he uses them to seek revenge
on the street gang that killed him in
his one true love the crow is intensely
dark and violent but in a way that never
feels mopey or gratuitous it is simply a
broken hearted superhero film that
embraces love and loss with open black
feathered wings
placing the third installment to the
mcu's iron man series this prominently
on an all-time list might be considered
controversial in some circles but we're
confident in this decision come on
following the events of the avengers
tony stark is at loose ends the arrival
of the mysterious terrorists known as
the mandarin makes things worse to say
nothing of the rocky road he and pepper
potts have begun to walk iron man 3
contains a clever second axe swerve one
of gwenet paltrow's best mcu turns and
barrels of acid quippery also a bunch of
people fall out of an exploding airplane
at one point and iron man figures out a
way to rescue them all it's awesome as
heck
until the day avengers vs justice league
enters production avengers infinity war
will remain the most crowded and
ambitious multi-franchise crossover
movie in existence intergalactic tyrant
thanos arrives on earth to collect the
only two infinity stones he hasn't yet
captured
the hardest choices require the
strongest wills
with the avengers the guardians of the
galaxy and so many other white hats
pulling together to halt thanos
malicious grandiosity surely the good
guys can't lose right they'll have to
try their hardest to stop the purple
batty from slaughtering half of all life
in the universe and even then it might
not be enough
the second half of the epic that begins
with avengers infinity war wisely
focuses on tony stark and steve rogers
as they struggle to undo thanos's cosmic
massacre time travel might just be the
ticket but they won't succeed without
incurring some wretching losses let me
go
no
it all culminates in an unforgettable
battle for all the marbles that people
will be talking about for decades to
come avengers end game elegantly ties
off the saga of two fantasy adventure
icons and launches the mcu into the
future
over the years the deliciously dark
batman returns has solidified its
reputation as one of the caped crusaders
most enduring cinematic escapades as
well as the best batflake of the 90s
michelle viver permanently etched her
image into the superhero genre by the
definitive turn as selena kyle who
becomes catwoman under intense duress
danny devito is uproariously savage and
sociopathic as the penguin and then
there's michael keaton's batman who's
attempting to keep both of them from
permanently harming gotham city it's
manic stylish and strange in other words
absolutely perfect
ironically one of disney's best
superhero offerings has nothing to do
with marvel state mandated retirement
forces bob parr aka mr incredible to
give up vigilantism his restlessness
makes him easy prey from the
manipulations of an enigmatic villain
known as syndrome whose ambitions and
career trajectory are not what they seem
luckily mr incredible's family is
uniquely positioned to help him out of
this jam as they incidentally also all
have superpowers
parenthood suburban malays and good
old-fashioned fisticuffs collide in this
pixar treasure
m night shyamalan followed up his
breakthrough this sixth sense with
another bruce willis-led mind bender
elijah price an obsessed comic book nerd
with a rare bone disease has a theory if
he was born much weaker than the average
person someone out there must have been
born much stronger than the average
person he thinks he's found his inverse
when david don miraculously survives a
train wreck that kills every other
passenger but david refuses to believe
he's superhuman even if he is there
might be more to the story now that we
know who you are
i know who i am
the first mcu entry from the russo
brothers is a twist pack thriller as
exciting as any alien-centric flick capp
black widow and nick fury join forces to
unravel a conspiracy with the potential
to derail all of civilization it
especially pulls the rug out from under
viewers with regards to shield the
alleged good guys who might actually be
irreparably infiltrated by terrorist
network hydra in the midst of it all is
the mysterious winter soldier an
assassin straight out of steve rogers's
past after batman and robin sucked the
dignity out of the dynamic duo the
franchise wisely defaulted back to
batman's broody formative years
why not send junior home early
i've got some
wild oats to sew
best known at the time of the movie's
debut for 2002's disorienting nail-biter
momento director and co-writer
christopher nolan presents a version of
gotham that feels truly unique bruce
wayne's origin story is on offer here
interpreted through an intensely gritty
lens he spends the first third of the
film acquiring his de facto superhuman
power of self-discipline the rest he
devotes to weaponizing the shadows
against the superstitious and cowardly
where are you
here
this might still not be enough to take
down the terrifying scarecrow however
a full-blown cultural phenomenon upon
its wildly successful 2018 debut black
panther remains the mcu's most
thoughtful and thematically rich chapter
king t'challa is introduced in captain
america civil war which frees black
panther up to go beyond the typical
origin story route in this film the new
head of state navigates a messy
geopolitical inheritance and confronts
wakanda's history of isolationism when
an estranged member of the royal family
comes calling t'challa must decide what
sort of king he wants to be and what
sort of country he wants to lead i must
take the mantle back i must
plus there's also a wicked boss car
chase scene
thor had multiple team-ups and solo
movies under his belt by 2017 but the
god of thunder still hadn't found a
clear cinematic identity until director
taika waititi took the reigns informed
by the psychedelic sensibilities of
1970s marvel comics thor ragnarok sends
its hero through the intergalactic
ringer stranded on the chaotic trash
planet zakar thor is forced to engage in
gladiatorial combat soon enough he
learns he's not alone a strange valkyrie
are here too oh and also the hulk
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
but they're not exactly jazzed about his
plan for escape or confronting hella his
long-lost sister who's grinding asgard
beneath her boot
the themes of quite a few superhero
movies basically boil down to a lead
character grappling with daddy issues
guardians of the galaxy volume 2 bounces
that subtext up to regular text as
star-lord finally encounters ego his
biological father a celestial being who
might not be all that he seems speaking
of father-son dynamics rocket raccoon
and baby groots establish themselves as
comedy legends as well as brutal killing
machines what is ego's plan for the
universe why did he leave in the first
place and what oh what is baby groot's
favorite song to jam out to the answers
might surprise you
the original superman happens to be the
prototype for just about every other
film on this list but it's also a
fantastic watch unto itself
easy miss i've got you
the familiar origin of the man of steel
plays out with spectacular sci-fi
grandeur which manages to feel retro
cool rather than dated lex luthor plans
to kill superman with a real estate scam
because it was the late 1970s and cgi
tech capable of depicting a brainiac or
starro is not yet available this doesn't
hurt the movie though to modernize it
makes it downright refreshing it helps
that christopher reeve and margot kidder
are freaking adorable as lois and clark
the mcu starts with iron man but it
doesn't feel completely real until its
first full-blown crossover project the
avengers let the world know that this
business about a shared movie universe
might have some staying power after all
a gathering of characters introduced in
prior films principally iron man captain
america and thor put aside their petty
differences to save new york city from a
mythological sorcerer aided by an army
of cosmic goblins as swarmy conqueror
loki tom hiddleston steals the show but
everyone's firing on all cylinders this
is the modern superhero movie in many
ways and will likely remain a classic
for decades to come
the follow-up to 2002's highly
encouraging spider-man doubles down on
peter parker as the sad sack
overburdened 20-something while
channeling director sam raimi's evil
dead honed horror sensibilities into
alfred molina's tragic dr otto octavius
peter just can't seem to handle being
spider-man in this film his powers are
on the fritz his grades are slacking and
his love life is frayed is fighting
crime really worth it meanwhile dr
octavius transformed into the villainous
doco threatens to destroy the city with
his scientific experiments but in truth
he's suffering an identity crisis of his
own not unlike a man with extra
mechanical arms spider-man 2 expertly
juggles multiple themes and plot lines
simultaneously stuffed to the brim with
deep dive references and providing a
welcoming gateway for new fans into the
spider-verse activates previously
untapped potential in spider-man's
origin story a radioactive spider bites
teenage miles morales bestowing upon him
the proportional strength and speed of
an arachnid plus invincibility and a
very cool finger zap power following the
death of peter parker miles must become
the new spider-man and train under the
guidance of peter parker things get even
more confusing when further spider
heroes pop up from wildly different
universes
[Music]
you're like me
this mesmerizing film is particularly
distinguished by its jaw-droppingly
innovative animation
the end of hugh jackman's 17-year nine
film run is the anchor of the x-men
movie franchise is one part
hyper-violent dystopian adventure one
part mega commentary on the modern
superhero boom and one part touching
father-daughter bonding story in a
brutal future the man known as wolverine
must shepherd mutankine's future to
safety in the form of laura a young girl
with a mysterious past their journey is
a tragic one yet also spiked with hope
logan which practically drips gravitas
out of its many stab wounds is the rare
superhero film that might make you cry
why so serious
we'll tell you exactly why we're
incredibly serious about the dark knight
it's the greatest superhero movie of all
time and one of the better films of the
2000s overall director christopher nolan
returns to gotham and levels up from
batman begins with a philosophical
slobber knocker between the joker's
sadistic chaos in batman's benevolent
order this is what happens when an
unstoppable force
meets
an immovable object
heath ledger won a posthumous oscar for
delivering a mass murdering bizarrely
charming joker who still pops on screen
all these years later meanwhile the rise
and fall of harvey dent provides a dark
knight with its thematic backbone
recommended for viewing at least once a
year
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite superhero movies are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]